alors déjà avant d'y aller on a vérifié
nos infos enfin on n'y a pas été non
plus sans sans garde-fou bien évidemment
que comme tous les autres on a entendu
parler de la rumeur que dans un premier
temps d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs
semaines elle ne se vérifient absolument
pas
la rumeur est revenu ces derniers jours
et là on a réactivé
ban aux sources voilà on a passé des
coups de téléphone on a cherché à
vérifier l'info et en l'occurrence on a
on a pu la vérifier vous êtes sûr de
l'info sur sur l'info donc là une fois
que vous êtes sûr de l'info vous dit on
y va on le fait après voilà gâtez vous
questionner la décision non enfin la
discussion elle il ya une discussion
avec avec l'éditeur évidemment de savoir
est ce qu on y va est ce qu'on n'y va
pas j'avais hésité vous écouter à partir
du moment où on avait l'info à 100%
l'hésitation elle est elle éliminée une
petite couère minimes bien sûr d'accord
donc quant aux commandes à cette info
qui vous la donner
et c'est parti d'une de parce que est-ce
que sont la femme d'eric zemmour locaux
alors ça moi je ne sais pas sur la femme
d'eric zemmour est au courant enfin là
en l'occurrence son mari elle est
maintenant en l'occurrence
l'information la rumeur tournait serre
que depuis la révélation enfin en tout
cas depuis les premiers papiers les
premières couvertures avec eric zemmour
et sarah knafo voilà il ya cette info là
qui est sorti tout de suite je vous dis
à l'époque elle ne se vérifiait pas en
tout cas on nous on n'a pas pu la
vérifier ce qui n'était pas le cas cette
fois ci ce que vous comprenez les
critiques de gens qui lisent on en
décompte pour la famille des règlements
pour son ex-femme pour ses enfants de
voir ça c'est c'est extrêmement violent
et même pour sarah knafou ce que vous
comprenez ou pas du tout ça non mais je
comprends après eric zemmour depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois est partis en
pré campagne présidentielle il annoncera
s'il sera ou pas candidat mais voilà il
est à
plus de 10% dans les sondages le donnent
en tout cas parfois au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
donc il devient une personnalité
politique de premier plan et à partir de
là quand on
voit son discours les valeurs qu'ils
prônent
le même vous reprenez ce que disent et
mathieu de la mode mais parce que c'est
aussi ce qui a motivé le choix de faire
cette couverture c'est à dire que au
delà de la révélation de route une
couverture politique est là elle a une
dimension politique je pense que les
gens les partisans d'eric zemmour qui
sont souvent des conservateurs et qui
ont une vision
très conservatrice de la famille seront
certainement contents d'apprendre que il
ya un décalage entre le discours est
l'homme qu'il est eric zemmour est le
papa long et bah oui est ce que
vous l'avez c'est aussi parce que vous
pensiez que les autres allaient le faire
vos concurrents voici public alors je
pense qu'on a tous travaillé sur cette
information je pense et myriam qu'on
adore aussi brillé chez public voilà
nous nous on respecte le travail de
chacun et même disait elle que l avait
ni citer qu'elles aient été palais mais
qu'elle regrettait de ne pas y être allé
alors voilà presse et des raisons qui
leur appartiennent
est ce que c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'ils étaient sûrs à 100% pas je ne
sais pas voilà en tout cas nous c'est un
gros coup pour vous oui bah oui je
regardais un engouement bas on sent que
en tout cas là ce soir déjà voilà et
puis sur les réseaux sociaux ça bouge
pas mal alors obéir il ya beaucoup de
critiques beaucoup de gens qui salue le
truc aussi pour regretter ou pas du tout
ah non pas du tout non un instant pas un
instant et puis voir à pas et est sous
embargo si si ça a était sous embargo
est sorti hier vous l'avez fait exprès
de le faire sortir pour non pas du tout
en fait bien évidemment que un coup
comme ça on laisse pas traîner au cadran
et que on a des manières de faire à la
rédaction pour que le pain que seuls les
gens qui ont besoin de travailler sur ce
truc soit au courant voilà c'est parfois
regrettable mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
75 % de la rédaction qui savaient pas ce
qu'on mettait en
avant ce matin comment il a su
l'entourage d'eric zemmour et eric se
met alors à près voilà où on a on a
quand même passé pas mal de coups de fil
aussi on a activé les choses donc il ya
certainement des choses qui leur sont
remontés par ce biais là vous avez qu'il
est quoi pourquoi pas pour vous bac est
énorme ça va pour vérifier l'information
oui bien sûr ouais ben voilà on encore
une fois on
on critique souvent la presse people
mais on bosse comme les autres c'est à
dire qu'on a une info on l'a vérifié et
si on si elle se vérifie pas on ne la
sors pas alors à quel moment vous êtes
dit on va le sortir quand on a eu
confirmation à 100% que qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous avez eu confirmation sont
présentes vais vraiment très proches bah
on a eu alors je peux pas après mois
détaillé sans mettre en péril bien sûr
régulièrement mais voilà moi j'ai hélas
j'ai quelque chose qui formellement me
dis que je me trompe pas en vacances à
une preuve réponse est
oui benjamin on sait on en a parlé hier
avec mariam palombes à elle disait que
même si vous vendez énormément de closer
avec cette une
avec ce que vous allez payer à eric
zemmour et sarah knafo qui ont qui vous
ont attaqué vous arriverez même pas à
harry à rentrer dans vos frais du
magazine s'ébroue pas par sa défense et
évaluez vous évaluez les risques qu'on
vous fait alors comme ça évidemment on
n'aime pas ça peut être pour vous
honnêtement je ne sais pas ils vont
certainement demander beaucoup d'argent
comme ils le font comme comme le font
quasiment tout le monde après est-ce
qu'ils obtiendront ça ça dépend des
jugements je suis pas je perds la tête
des juges ou provisionné ça quand même
enfin évidemment on prévoit on prévoit
oui oui bien sûr mais
mais voilà après c'est pareil sur les
ventes effectivement il ya un buzz est
ce que les gens vont aller en kiosque
d'accord on souhaite évidemment penser
que l'un dans l'autre et les deux
gagnants
je sais pas en tout cas on fait parler
du magazine
voilà ça c'est le vote le plus gros coup
depuis françois hollande oui je pense
c'est ça les croissants au françois
hollande way des scouts de françois
hollande il était quand même magique
macérer c'était c'était énorme
c'est votre deuxième plus gros court
mais voilà oui c'est un euro considèrent
que c'est un bon tour et est ce que eric
zemmour pourrait faire interdire la
publication du magazine parce que c'est
ce qu'on a dit alors il a il a essayé
effectivement par quels moyens qu s'est
implanté en fait en fait il a donc ils
ont ils ont su
que nous sortions ou en tout cas qu'il y
avait une possibilité que l'on sorte une
couverture sur sur eric zemmour et sara
quin faux ils ont fait ce qu'on appelle
un référé d'heure à heure c'est à dire
que ils ont par le biais de leur avocat
fait un une procédure juridique de
l'urgence on appelle ça la procédure de
l'urgence quand c'est ça qui peut faire
interdire c'est l'état d'urgence
explique aux téléspectateurs c'est une
procédure à laquelle on fait appel si on
veut vraiment à dire quelque chose dans
l'immédiat tout de suite c'était elle
n'a pas abouti et en fait voilà après il
s'était fait scientiste des émissions de
télé parfois des émissions qu'il ya des
procès sur dating sur des choses on peut
dire voilà on fait une procédure
d'urgence pour interdire l'émission de
passer cela visiblement ils ont pas il
n'avait pas d'arguments ou en tout cas
de choses assez convaincante pour
convaincre le juge de l'urgence de
l'interdiction de notre parution
donc voila et ils ont leur demande a été
jugée recevable
et ils ont été condamnés je crois à
payer chacun 3000 euros au titre de
l'article 700 est ce que vous attendiez
à ce qui vous assigne oui alors qu'on
est une assignation a posteriori oui à
priori honnêtement non voilà après la
signer c'est quoi la pire assignation
vous ayez enfin la pire peine que vous
ayez condamnation voilà vous avez payé
combien pour le truc qui vous a coûté
plus d'un alors ce n'était pas de mon
fait mais c'était la famille royale
d'angleterre à l'époque où il y avait eu
le scandale autour des saints de kate
middleton ah ouais voilà qui restera je
pense une condamnation mais étaient
c'était wayne en plus que ça et c'était
autour de 5000 euros je trouverais de
mémoire un jeu pas tout à fait sûre du
chiffre mais voilà ah ouais mais bon
voilà le royal et ils ont mis un coup
digne dans les violences
est ce que est ce que eric zemmour ça
marche en ligne de magazines et coûté en
tout cas voilà on dira je vous fais
envers les chefs cible c'est une cible
en tout cas il ya un intérêt médiatique
autour de sa personne on n'est pas les
seuls à parler lui il est quand même
c'est ce même quand il n'est pas
présente sur les plateaux télé ou en une
des magazines son nom est quand même
site et donc effectivement il ya un
intérêt il ya un engouement et on s'y
intéresse comme tous les autres médias
voilà à travers le prisme le qui est le
nôtre à savoir aussi le prisme de la vie
privée alors eric zemmour a réagi sur
twitter quoi qu'il arrive toujours et
partout je défendrai jalousement
férocement ma vie privée et celle de mes
proches
la vie publique oui le voyeurisme non
désolé pour les pervers si vous lui
répondez à ça ben que évidemment il va
pas cautionner notre une je m'attendais
pas à moins de sa part après la vie
publique
quand on brigue un poste comme celui de
président de la république
ben voilà c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être un
il a comment la frontière est assez
ténue entre entre entre la vie publique
et la vie privée on l'a vu à d'autres
occasions
pour pour d'autres d'autres
personnalités politiques en l'occurrence
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
aile elle montre aussi le décalage entre
le discours qui peut porter dans les
médias ou dans ses livres et
le et l'homme et l'homme qu'il est voilà
alors que les avocats d'eric zemmour est
sûre avec la foa fientes
[Musique]
closer présuppose que sarah knafo
on veut parler la clause ne présuppose
que sarah cna vous en tiendrez ni
entretiendrait une relation intime avec
eric zemmour et serait tombée enceinte
de ce dernier il est patent que sarah
knafo n'a donné aucune autorisation à la
révélation des détails de sa supposée
maternité lesquels relèvent
intégralement de sa vie privée ce qu'ont
dit les avocats et de votre côté le
magazine closer s'est défendu c'est
extrêmement grave de demander la saisie
d'un journal surtout quand la demande
provient d'un journaliste c'est ce que
vous avez expliqué il ya un instant sur
wii voilà c'est vrai que ça nous a un
peu étonné parce que eric zemmour avant
d'être candidat à la présidentielle ou
un homme politique il était quand même
journaliste et c'est quand même assez
bon étonnant de voir quelqu'un qui lui
même s'est dit parfois censure et quand
le csa a voulu des comptes et son temps
de parole à l'antenne il avait fait des
vidéos pour dire qu'ils étaient censurés
bon ben voilà deux pour un journaliste
de vouloir faire interdire un magazine
c'est sewell c'est pas ça bon voilà
c'est ça pose question quoi